on the next all-new Rick and Morty Oh
flat tire how'd you get a flat tire in
space Rick? Morty, get back in the car I'm not in danger.
there's nothing out here early
everything is out here and unlike
everywhere else I'm too busy to help
right because you're always so helpful
yeah first sure getting in there right
on time with the dragon it was right
right at the peak of dragon hysteria
definitely a good idea always the show
that takes three years to make an
episode to leap on trends
Morty gets a dragon and things do
not go well because dragons are from
fantasy and that doesn't really play
well with Rick's sci-fi world you have
no magic yeah I know I have actual power
not here you don't
it's kind of an episode about also like
relationships and toxic relationships
you slut dragon I felt like that the dragon
kind of rebellion it we must begin at
is the path to defeat the patriarchy
this episode starts the conversation and
I think I should get probably some medal
for that a Webby I would accept that
Daytime Emmy okay I'll bite what's with
the talking cat, the cats subplot was an
attempt to just have fun the cat
represents that voice in your head in
the writers room it's like you're
overthinking it just have fun it came
from like it was Disney movies like
Oliver and company or anything like that
like they never really explained why the
cats can talk
the cat is here to save Jerry from
overthinking it, where's the cat?
welcome back everyone its Charlie this is going to be my Rick and Morty season 4 episode 5
trailer video there's a whole bunch of
Easter eggs we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're doing
a new round of the merch giveaway - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best evil
Morty theory on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this - the
title of the episode is rattle star Ricklactica
a reference to Battlestar
Galactica it's not clear if it's a
reference to the original series or the
reboot series that Ronald D Moore did so
if you didn't see it earlier this year
Justin roiland implied in an interview
at Comic Con that this would be one of
the important canonical episodes of
season four with the big post credit
scene tag than some story teasers that
would carry over into season 5 he wasn't
clear if he was just miss speaking and
talking about the second half of season
4 or if it's legit something that we
won't see paid off till way later next
year in actual season 5 episodes they
still haven't set an exact date for the
second half of season 4 but I'm assuming
it's sometime in January till we hear
something otherwise the actual season
five episodes probably won't premiere
til either the next summer or later at
the end of next year like around the
same time that we got season 4 this year
if we get any updates or any official
information about that I'll be sure to
include it in one of my videos but in
the scene which kind of feels like the
cold open just based on the energy
Rick gets a flat tire in space for some
strange reason because apparently the
tires don't fully retract into the ship
and he has to stop to change it they
turn it into a bit about how anything
can happen in space even getting bit by
a random snake that just happens to be
wearing a spacesuit for some strange
reason the joke kind of feels like it
was pitched by a writer who got bit by a
snake while changing their tire on the
side of the highway or something like
that this is the first time we've seen
those space suits but it's implied that
Rick's spaceship has hundreds of
different secret weapons and abilities
that they mostly just use for a comedy
at random times like the random meeseeks box that he keeps in the glove
compartment that we just learned about
this season he probably still has his
ready to go because the only one that we
saw them used was the one inside fascist
Rick's spaceship and the whole idea is
that each version of Rick shares a lot
of similarities with only a few things
being different like being a wasp or a
teddy bear or a teddy bear this a
fascist
morty being kind of a dumbass as usual
it doesn't see the danger of space
because he hasn't learned about all the
things that can happen in space it just
assumes that rick is being an asshole
trying to tell him what to do sometimes
it can be hard to tell when rick is just
making fun of you and making stuff up
but most of the time when he warns
Morty's summer Beth and Jerry about
something it's because there is real
danger so of course morty gets bit by a
random snake wearing a spacesuit there
was more this clip that was in the
season 4 trailer where rick complains
because morty is whining too much about
dying
I don't know I'm just usually around
people that die faster the snakes
spacesuit even has a little flag on it
it's cut off in frame so you can't tell
what it's a reference to but there was
also a longer version of this entire
clip from before they get out of the
spaceship but the clip that Adult Swim
used in one of the earlier videos is
heavily water marked with Warner Media
with warnings not to use it so I can't
just straight up drop the clip in this
video but it's Rick making this huge
Saturday Night Live joke when Morty gets
out of the ship against his orders
he's as you young people think this
space is like Saturday Night Live you
see it every day you dream of being in
it but it dreams of removing all the air
from your body in making you float
around it for eternity as a flash
mummified corpse which is also what
space wants so get back in the car so
I'm kind of assuming that Dan Harmon
wrote that joke because it's so utterly
specific in its take down of Saturday
Night Live apparently Dan Harmon not a
big fan of Saturday Night Live but
beyond the Battlestar Galactica and
snakes reference I think this episode is
also supposed to be the terminator
parody with the snakes because of a
different clip from one of the earlier
trailers with some footage that we still
haven't seen during this season yet it
all the scenes from the trailer that
they dropped at the beginning of this
season is meant to be real scenes from
these episodes the first five episodes
the only time they drop fake scenes is
when it's for the intro and only some of
those scenes are fake I actually think
that we found our first real intro scene
for episode 5 here's the earlier trailer
with that Terminator snakes clip in it
and season four it's the forest of all
seasons because it's the fourth one it's
a lot different from season three we've
got a lot of a lot of shoot-'em-ups a
lot of laser shoot-'em-up so this is
just them doing the first Terminator
movie with snakes you have all these
Terminator snakes coming for more tea
then this one dressed like Kyle Reese
from the first movie coming to save him
for some reason so apparently more tea
is the Sarah Connor of this Terminator
equation but that also implies that the
Terminator snakes part of the new intro
is one of the real scenes keep in mind
though that there are still five more
episodes in season four technically so
there are a lot of these other intro
scenes that could wind up in episodes
but it's not clear why these cybernetic
snakes keep coming after Rick and Morty
who's behind them if they're doing a
terminator parody there has to be some
kind of Skynet if they're dropping a big
season five teaser does that mean it has
something to do with evil Morty he is
one of the few major ongoing canonical
villains of the series that they keep
bringing back and if it's going to be a
Battlestar Galactica reference who is
going to be they're Cylons is that who
these terminator snakes are but they
hype the hell out of that upcoming tag
scene back at comic-con
I'm still like obsessed with this this
like tag you guys don't know man we have
a dragon season 4 that's good I want to
I wanted to record it and sake not I'm
like I can't say but I don't get to
record it but like it's maybe my most
favorite speech it's so good it's so
good then the response it's just it's so
good the finale of season 4 is really
good yeah can we get Kaname yeah you
guys so based on all the stuff that
they're hyping up and what we know about
the episode so far let me know in the
comments what do you think is going on
with the Terminator snakes and what is
that post credit scene going to be
teasing season 5 stuff they also kind of
imply that Beth has a special story
during the finale now I don't know if
that's going to be the continuing saga of
is Beth a clone or not if that's
something that they'll go back to
because the way the writers talked about
it after season 3 is that they hadn't
really thought that far ahead they were
just kind of throwing that question out
there for fans to wonder about but there
was that whole storyline during season 3
episode 9 that was teasing the idea that
Beth had just as much potential as Rick
so Rick was telling her to just go out
and tie a bow on the universe go out and
have some fun and the ugly truth has
always been but I'm not that great a guy
and you're exactly like me so other big
question in the comments let me know
what you think that special Beth story
is going to be and when I do post my
episode 5 video next week I will rank
all the season 4 episodes so far there
was also a cool real-life Rick and Morty
thing that happened to me last week the
Adult Swim people the Rick and Morty
people and the people behind the turo
car service made an actual Morty card
that they let me drive so I'll post a
clip of that in my next Rick and Morty
bonus video which apply beyond Friday if
there any special Rick and Morty bonus
videos that you want me to do just let
me know in the comments big reminder
about the second half of season 4 I'm
assuming that'll air sometimes starting
at the end of January until they say
otherwise but I'm hoping that they drop
an official promo just teasing exactly
when that's going to happen sometime
before the end of the year Adult Swim
can be kind of weird with the way they
release information sometimes they don't
tell you what's happening till right
before it happens which is kind of
annoying
and I'll say congratulations to the
giveaway winner for my last big Rick &
Morty video Almighty Sosa 300 please
email me on the about page my channel so
I can get your details
everyone click here for my Rick and
Morty season 4 episode 4 video and click
here for my new Mandalorian baby yoda
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight!